I have a very funny story to tell you I
was at my dermatologist today she was
with her girlfriend and they came to the
conclusion that they both wanted to have
a menage it came out of nowhere I don't
know where and she asked me do I know
anybody I said yeah but it'll cost you a
thousand bucks I was thinking of you me
do you need the money and I'm closing
shop I am NOT a beautiful man
you speak Czech a beautiful man who an
experienced lover why shouldn't you get
paid for it I saw myself getting a small
fee if you were a pimp you gotta have a
name I'll be damned bomber it's nice to
meet you Dan maybe I should try your guy
out first alone just me and him you do
this often no I mean so this is kind of
a part-time thing you could say that oh
she tipped you you know waitresses cool
ear tips and they split them we got
another customer maybe more yeah have a
word-of-mouth
I think god bless you girls
[Music]
is it oh yeah I really think that I
should try I like it rough
sometimes I even like to be the man just
strap on my god hmm yeah so this is what
you do we bring magic to the world
that's one way to put it
he's shy so why handle it that you are
flirting with me
no yes and just to do the low
everybody needs contact they need love
they need affection if you do remember
that a threesome is into 2,000 bucks
these vulnerable people think of it as a
performance they are very nice days work
let me tell you that goes on without me
have you ever heard any panache attire
1977 during a blackout nobody could see
anything but we're still very pleasant
[Music]